thank you all for coming so um i'm going
to be talking a bit about moden and
scaling pandas
um
i guess this is my clicker um so yeah
i'm devin i'm the co-founder and cto of
ponder um and we'll just jump right in
here uh i hope
good okay um so a little bit about me i
come from somewhat of a non-traditional
background um i was in the marine corps
for four years
um as a korean crypto linguist uh from
2008 to 2012 and then after that i went
and got my
my bachelor's degree at the university
of missouri
from there i went to berkeley to work on
my phd and i was very fortunate to get a
lot of support there which kind of let
me explore a lot of interesting problems
and uh
you know moden which is the main topic
of this talk started as my phd project
and it really started from this
uh
this goal that i had of empowering
scientists empowering data scientists
and now of course i'm the co-founder and
cto of ponder
so
the talk is about moden and um i want to
talk about how we built this this data
frame architecture from first principles
and and so um a fair warning we get into
some pretty deeply technical components
hopefully if i've done a good job in
this talk
everybody will be able to take something
from it so
um you know i talk about things at
different levels and try to map to
different things you'll see you'll see
so
um
but yeah so
starting out i kind of wanted to talk
about uh organizational problems in data
science and i don't think these really
talked about enough because
uh we like to talk about scale and like
and and how data teams don't scale
and and everybody wants to think about
the machine and how the machine doesn't
scale but i'm not actually going to
focus on machine scalability in terms of
this talk i i'm actually more interested
in
data teams so uh one of the big
challenges these days is is hiring
everybody knows that right
but even beyond that we've seen data
teams
uh double in size triple in size and not
actually end up
providing more production models
not providing more more production jobs
right we're not seeing a lot of benefit
from
from hiring all of these all these
additional folks and it's it's really
caused a lot of bottlenecks and so if we
if we kind of take a step back and take
a look at what a lot of organizations
look like um when they're doing data
science what we see is that often things
start out in this uh you know laptop or
workstation type environment where
you're you're prototyping with pandas
and you're you know you get new specs
new data new uh new business
requirements from somebody else right so
so you're kind of prototyping and then
you hand it off
you hand it off to somebody else or
maybe you rewrite it
but you have to use a different tool if
you want to run it in some testing or
production environment so there's a
rewrite involved you see there and that
takes time human time right we're
talking about human scalability and
human time is the limit here
and then when we look at production
um you know there's there's an
additional rewrite and some you know
some companies skip testing and that
sort of thing or testing and production
are are very
kind of similar environments um but all
of this is to say that there's there's a
lot of kind of rewriting that goes into
data science and and trying to actually
productionize something and then perhaps
the worst of all is when something goes
wrong in production you get feedback or
you're you know your assumptions were
incorrect or there's a bug
another rewrite but this time it has to
go all the way back to the data
scientists because the the initial
assumptions were incorrect or the the
sampling was
uh you know the data sample was was
tarnished in some way so there's
there's just a lot of time that is put
into each and every phase here and and
often it involves multiple people and
there are multiple points at which these
folks have to have to kind of coordinate
and this is this is obviously extremely
frustrating for data teams it's
frustrating for data scientists
especially for data engineers and
machine learning engineers and software
engineers everybody involved is really
uh really frustrated by this process
because
it just takes so much time so much human
time
and so the the data science scalability
that that i want to talk about is
actually this human scalability issue
that we have where
we're not actually getting
more out of more people uh and a lot of
this comes from
this issue of of having to constantly
rewrite things so
uh
it's really easy to spin up more compute
right just
give amazon a million dollars you can
have as much compute as you want but
you can't do that with data science it
takes months to hire a data scientist
right it takes
it takes a lot of time to ramp this
person up and to get them to be
productive on your team so their their
time is is extremely extremely valuable
so why is this why do we have things set
up the way that we do right why are
why are the why are there so many phases
of rewriting well
there's there's this matrix right and
there's there's usability and there's
performance scalability right so
pandas
you may disagree with me here but pandas
is easy to use in that
data scientists can take a boot camp
they can kind of get started almost
immediately and they don't need to have
like a like a super deep
understanding of computer science
fundamentals to actually go and be
productive with pandas
that's not true if you want to use some
big data tool right if you want to use a
big data framework you kind of have to
understand
cluster computing you have to you have
to get an idea of of what partitioning
is and and how to how to kind of split
your data you have to understand when
things are executing and when they
aren't and so there are all these extra
kind of cognitive overheads
that we put on on folks who
who are who are translating things to
these big data frameworks so
our goal ponder's goal
is to basically make
data science tools work for the data
scientists right we shouldn't be
having to
you know
try so hard and make and like work for
our tools the tools should actually be
working for us
so
our
our whole
kind of
goal is to transparently scale
existing systems and so we started with
pandas
and moden is our open source project
um
that
you know it scales pandas and it allows
you to run pandas on a variety of
different execution engines a variety of
different databases um and and really
what we're doing is we're abstracting
away all these complicated details about
how
data scientists actually don't care
about how right they they just want to
be able to
you know submit their query they want to
be able to write write things in a
familiar language it's
there's nothing about distributed
computing that kind of overlaps with
their goals so we want to abstract away
all these details and and just make make
them more powerful this also has
benefits for data engineers because now
they don't have to be the ones to do
this translation right so um i'll talk a
little bit more about this later but but
a lot of the the kind of pull for moden
has actually come from
data engineering teams who who are
saying like we've been working around
pandas for years and we're tired of it
please please come and and do this for
us so
um
but we'll talk a little bit more about
that uh in a bit
um and so where we want to where we want
ponder to kind of fit is is here at the
top right where where we can build tools
that are both usable
and scalable both easy to use
and performant
so
naturally let's start from first
principles so this is where things will
start to get a little bit more technical
i'll start at a high level but
a lot of this work started as my phd
work and so um
you know we'll
we'll get into
some theory
but but we'll start at a high level so
don't be don't be too worried before i
start there though a lot of people i see
a lot of people
say the pandas api is not scalable
i think that's kind of a mistake to
think to think about things like that um
an api can't really be skilled it's sql
scalable it it doesn't you can you can
have a scalable implementation of sql
the pandas api is just a way of
expressing computation and so when we
when we
went after this problem from first
principles really what we wanted to do
is
is take pandas and and say that it is
just a way of expressing computation we
just need a way to kind of
you know be able to express this in math
and be able to optimize it and kind of
abstract away all these details that you
get for free when you're using sql right
so um
so anyway i just wanted to kind of
preface with this because um i kind of i
kind of hear this a lot so
um okay so if we're if we're solving
data frames from first principles
this is kind of all the stuff we have to
do and you see implementation is last
uh naturally we
want to make sure that we know what a
data frame is and that we know what it
can do
first
but we'll walk through these i'm i'm uh
i'm not going to stick on this slide too
long so the first thing that we did was
we formalized the data frame
and in formalizing the data frame we
wrote a paper basically targeted at
sql users database users and database
researchers actually and this was in
vldb2020 excuse me
okay um
so
we all love databases we know what a
database is um
we
we love the relational data model right
it's simple
uh and it's it's fairly
expressive excuse me um
i'm gonna draw an analogy here to kind
of restaurants um so
if we think about a relational database
we can really think about it as kind of
a michelin star
restaurant where
it has a
dress code you can't just go in wearing
what you want you you have a highly
curated menu with a very select set of
things that you can do and it's highly
optimized and and does a an excellent
job
at what it does right a michelin star
restaurant
um
you know is highly tuned food for
a subset of the menu
now if we look at pandas pandas is a lot
more
like a food court if you will so it's a
different data model different apis
there are over 600 apis and and i'll get
more into the details about like
how we actually derive the data model in
a little bit but pandas like i mentioned
is like a food court where
there is no dress code you can kind of
do whatever you want you can do
something
even a little bit unnatural like get
sushi and french fries together so
there's there's no rules effectively to
what you can do within the confines of
that food court so
if we if we kind of directly compare
the relational database
to a pandas data frame um on the kind of
convenience side what we have is
we have this
query
this difference in how you actually
express queries so in sql you of course
it's all or nothing you kind of express
your whole query up front whereas with
pandas you're kind of incrementally
building your query over time
there's also a very strict schema that's
enforced on the data so you cannot
uh you have to know the schema up front
and the schema is actually defined first
it's defined before you can even put any
data into the database
in pandas this is not the case in pandas
you don't need to define a schema up
front it will actually infer the schema
for you it will determine the schema for
you
and then lastly
versatility
pandas also kind of has an advantage
here
because
really what you can do with sql is
select from where group i join right so
um
pandas has
a very expressive language over 600
functions
of things that you can do
now this might sound like i'm telling
you all to go use pandas if you don't
like pandas uh you do not have to use
pandas trust me but
uh there's a reason why people use
pandas and we will never get people to
stop using pandas so the best thing that
we can do
is
try to rebuild this thing from the
ground up
naturally everybody loves pandas like i
was mentioning um so
it's it's often described as the reason
for for python's popularity the reason
for python support and it kind of was
inherited over time it it was built in
in the community by by a large community
um
so uh for those of you who are kind of
like
computer science history buffs uh
data frames actually first emerged in s
which was which was uh
a language that was created in bell labs
and then um r is the open source version
of s
um
you know these are kind of
a little bit more refined languages uh
for for
operating on the data frame and then
pandas of course kind of just
went
wild with trying to implement as many
useful things as possible um and and i
think that that really
has contributed a lot to its success
so um
now let's jump into the the kind of
formalism and i'm
i'm uh i'm not going to read this to you
i don't uh
if you're interested please go read the
paper uh there's probably not even
enough context on this page to really
give the whole picture because um
we wrote a whole paper about it so
please if you're interested you can talk
to me afterwards as well i'm i'm happy
to talk um
but in general the the data frame data
model is
uh it's an ordered data model um so
what that means is that it's it's not
necessarily sorted by any individual
column or key
um
but there is some kind of a semantic
order to
to the data frame and and that order is
actually used often in
in things like window functions and um
even in just debugging and printing out
the data frame the first five lines
right um you know this this speaks to
the kind of
quick iteration that people that people
use pandas for so
um
there's also no predefined schema
necessary
uh this is another big difference from
from relational databases you can induce
the schema and infer the schema at
runtime effectively so
um that kind of explains why it emerged
in like r and python which have runtime
type errors that you know don't really
pop up in compile languages so um
so
there's also this this idea of named
rows and columns
um
you know named rows and columns are
are useful for
you know
moving metadata to data and data to
metadata this row names has like
traditionally been a kind of a
controversial thing but i i don't think
that row names are really uh
you know that special it's just like a
column that you can
do a select statement on it's it's not
really all that all that tricky um and
then there's also you know indexing by
label or by name so positional notation
um and that's where the order kind of
comes from so you can
i'm so clumsy i'm sorry um
i knew this was gonna happen too okay
i'm gonna put the cap back on
all right all right um so uh so grabbing
the kth row actually uh means something
right or grabbing the first k rows
actually means something there's a
um yeah so um and then of course there's
name notation which is uh
you know
indexing by that
rose name or that columns name
okay so um looking at this from two
different perspectives often it's really
easy to kind of it's it's easier to
compare this to like an existing data
model and this is where i'm starting to
get into the weeds and and so um
but i i really wanted everyone to be
able to take something from this talk so
um
from from a relational data from from a
relational algebra perspective um you
can kind of contrast data frames from
the relational data model
um in the following ways so uh it's it's
basically ordered uh
relational tables are not
are not ordered um
it has named rows which is is not really
a concept in uh in databases uh a lazily
induced schema
this
just wouldn't work on uh on a lot of
databases um
column names of arbitrary type this is
because data can become metadata and and
vice versa um and there's this column
and row symmetry so um
you know there's a transpose ability and
and you know transpose by itself isn't
really useful but what it does unlock is
is really interesting things like pivots
and um and those sorts of operations
that are typically pretty tricky to do
in uh in like a relational database and
of course there's also like support for
linear algebra operators like matrix
multiply so you can basically pass a
pandas data frame to scikit-learn and
it'll know it'll basically just rip off
the labels and kind of handle it from
there
from the linear algebra side we have
it's a heterogeneous data model so
instead of like
being being kind of one data type um
it's it's more of like a matrix-like
data structure
because it does preserve that order in
the same way that a matrix does
it also has both numeric and non-numeric
types
and explicit row and column labels of
course which
don't exist in the kind of matrix realm
indexing
in addition to indexing by position
which you can do in a matrix uh you also
can index by these labels and then of
course
support for like relational algebra
operators like a join which don't
don't really mean anything i'm going to
hit this like a thousand times so
oh
okay
all right so now we have a data frame
data model okay and it took us a while
to get here but uh
remember we're trying to to operate from
first principles we're trying to build
this data frame from ground up really
understand what it is and what we need
to implement so we can start to scale
panda's workflows so
now that we have a data model now we
need to look at what a data frame can do
and so
our natural next step was to actually
derive a data frame algebra and
derive this from pandas in a way that
can allow us to express everything in
pandas in like kind of a concise grammar
and and so um
the the challenge here though is that
pandas is just enormous like it's huge
this is
this is intractable really uh it's taken
a long time for them to kind of uh
develop pandas in this way and add all
this functionality right so if me a grad
student is trying to go in and like
scale pandas there's no way that i'm
ever going to be able to catch up so
uh so this this kind of algebra and this
grammar had multiple functions uh one of
the functions was to be able to
implement multiple of these operators at
a time because there does happen to be a
lot of uh duplication in the pandas api
so um
in in short here is what uh
the the kind of algebra looks like the
the mathematical representation of
um
the basically the data frame algebra and
what we can do with this math is we can
start to think about how we can reorder
things how we can uh
you know take a query and and really
optimize it in uh in terms of
of
order of operations
um and so you'll see here also that
multiple apis map to the same function
that's by design um so
in practice there's there's about 16
operators um that are that it makes
sense to implement uh and as an algebra
you know this is very expressive but we
kind of had to
you know express beyond this in order to
get uh
you know
the optimal performance so um
we also like i was getting my phds so of
course you have to prove your work so uh
we did a proof by exhaustion this was
just a lot of like
book work kind of like hand
writing work so um
but yeah we have a kind of a proof by
exhaustion that uh that we can express
all the pandas apis in in this concise
grammar and now we have an algebra and
so the algebra actually uh
you know
the next steps after the algebra is how
do we parallelize this algebra right how
do we how do we take these operators and
make them run in parallel
and so uh naturally the next step was a
set of decomposition rules where we can
take a data frame and split it up into
smaller chunks and and and try to think
about how
how we can run these things in parallel
um
parallelization is of course the the
kind of one of the more simple ways of
getting an optimization uh for for any
given query and so the the really
interesting thing about data frame
queries is that uh they fall into three
main camps i mean there are a couple of
others in addition to this around like
joints and and sorts and that sort of
thing but they fall into into three main
camps this the cell wise operators
where you're kind of uh anonymously
applying a function across each cell
individually
that's a little more rare
then there are these row wise operators
and the row wise operators are a lot
similar to
like your traditional sql operators
excuse me
okay and then
of course column wise
excuse me
sorry about that um
okay
so we have three different ways of
parallelizing operators um
and the tricky part about this
is that you have to support all these in
the same system so you can't just
naively go in and partition things
across rows
because the next operator may require
you to partition things across columns
so you have to have a kind of an
effective
way of moving between rows row row
parallelism and column parallelism
excuse
me so i promise i'm not trying to pad
the runtime or anything of this talk
uh this always seems to happen to me um
okay and then of course the type system
i'm not going to go into the details of
these things but
we developed the type system and and
defined the order semantics of every
operator that we that we have in the in
the algebra
and so now we have enough to kind of go
and
build an implementation
so since we have all this knowledge
about what a data frame is what a data
frame can do how we can parallelize this
how we can translate pandas down to this
to this algebra we have all of this
knowledge now so now we can actually go
and implement something and so moden is
that implementation modem is the
implementation that we
that we built uh
from first principles and so
it's
it's really easy to use it was actually
designed as a drop in replacement um
and and
we can be a drop in replacement because
we
we understand the pandas api and how it
maps to you know our internal
representation and our internal query
language so um
it's really easy to use of course and
it's really really easy to install uh
those are the the two biggest challenges
to getting people to use your stuff so
we wanted to make that as easy as
possible
um and so
we i spent a lot of time on this
formalism and and hopefully you all take
away something from that but
what i wanted to point out here is that
there we get a lot from that formalism
right we get
we get a lot from understanding the data
model
pandas pandas has a certain feel to it
that's hard to kind of mimic um and so
with this formalism we can
we can get that feeling that you get
from plans where you're really kind of
controlling the data but we don't have
to bring along all the baggage of like
having the the physical implementation
or having the physical order match the
logical order the user's preferred order
right we can we can decouple a lot of
these things that that are tightly
coupled in pandas because we because we
have a good understanding of the data
model because we spent a lot of this
time
on kind of drilling down and actually
getting to the core of what a data frame
is um and on the algebra side
you know of course there's a smaller
surface to implement i think that's uh
that's a given and i already mentioned
that but another really interesting
thing that we that we can do is we can
actually map these operators to other
systems that have an implementation like
a like a relational database for example
and so
uh what we're building at ponder is
this
idea of pandas on everything
and we can
we can express
these pandas queries in our low-level
programming language uh in our low-level
algebra language
and then we can we can either directly
implement them on
we can either directly implement them on
a uh on a compute engine like ray or
dask we can we can map them or push down
queries to a database for example and so
we get a lot of
a lot of power from from having this
algebra because we can we can actually
express it in a variety of different
languages
and so if you recall that this is how a
lot of organizations look with all of
the rewrites and all the time
how modern is actually being used in
practice is
basically as
this this one layer where you implement
things you have that one api and then
everybody
we just basically
you flip a switch and it's automatically
distributing your code underneath the
hood
and so you know with this we've had a
tremendous impact and i feel very
fortunate that we have such a such a
strong community
um
you know we've
it's it's really grown and it started as
my phd project so i i feel very
fortunate that i picked a uh
i picked a challenging project but but
also that i was able to you know build
this community um
yeah and so
um
yeah if you're a user of mode and i'd
love to hear from you
um so i wanted to talk i wanted to kind
of drill down on a couple of case
studies um
that that kind of come from our
community
and one of them is this uh this
e-commerce company that
um
basically everybody runs into panda's
problems at some point right and so um
these folks were able to basically uh
drop in moden or just replace the import
statement and process 1000x the data
faster than they were with pandas
so um
tremendous results they were
very happy and it kind of unblocked a
lot of their uh
a lot of their internal processes
and and kind of
yeah i mean they were they were happy um
there's also another another interesting
use case that's kind of emerged where um
companies migrating from one system to
another uh have kind of started adopting
moden
um
to to help with that process so if
so moden can basically uh
push queries down to both
of these systems
so it's just a matter of switching a
knob and mode in
when you want to migrate rather than
having to spend you know thousands of
human hours rewriting every script to
make sure that it's pointing at the
right data source and that sort of thing
so um
so we we've had some uh
some
some pretty good success with
you know folks just dropping moden in
and and having it
just kind of alleviate a lot of their
problems
um and so the
the last thing that i kind of want to
highlight is uh
another interesting thing is that a lot
of folks are like bringing their own
database their own sql
layer or or something like that and um
kind of plugging it in underneath of
mode and weave and have folks who um
who are bringing in graph database
so like to have a pandas run on top of
their graph database so um if you if you
are one of these folks talk to me please
um
i'd love to hear from you um
but but yeah that's uh that's another
really interesting use case because you
know it kind of unlocks the pandas user
group
you know for your database
okay so um
this is
this has been great i really appreciate
all your attention
i spent a lot of time on formalism and i
got pretty deeply technical so
thank you so much for your attention i
don't get a lot of opportunity to kind
of talk about my phd work and that sort
of thing and i hope you all took
something away from it um
so
we built this
the system mode in and we and we did it
by trying to kind of
rethink
the data frame
it's it's always very tempting to kind
of try to chip away at kind of the the
things that we know how to parallelize
well or try to you know
only focus on a subset or say that
pandas is bad but pandas isn't going
anywhere and so you know what we what we
really sought to do is
kind of
take this pandas community and just
empower them and and not tell them that
they're wrong not tell them that they
need to change and um
and so yeah that's um
that's it and there's a lot of deep
technical problems that still exist a
lot of interesting stuff going on a lot
of interesting stuff coming from ponder
in the next year so you know
stay tuned and
yeah anyway um
thank you and thank you for putting up
with my water antics that was like not
scripted but